will a disclaimer here the Lamborghini
Aventador is my all-time favorite sports
car and that's really almost all you
sell the Aventador and the oricon right
yes we are to model company we sell less
than demand this is one of the things we
have to tackle because luxury business
is always very limited and the budokan
is going great the Aventador is now
since 2011 on the market we had the road
san 13 we had now the super veloce at
the geneva motor show which is doing
great so we are very happy so why only
25 30 do you want to keep this limited
field this exclusiveness or is it just
hard to produce that many of these cars
it's a bit of everything it's they have
a long life cycle you have to invest a
lot of money the market is very low so
there is around the globe not more than
30,000 super sports car sold and for the
event order for example we're selling an
average of a thousand which is the
double of the predecessor which was the
Mesilla go so we're doing a good job
there that the car is very attractive on
the hood I can we start a production in
summer we presented the car in March at
the geneva motor show and this year we
have the opportunity to be better than
2530 the first quarter was great let's
see what is going to happen if no major
crises are coming up we can be better
how is the I'm a little bit obsessed and
I got to drive this Aventador on the new
jersey motorsports track actually here's
a video of me actually doing that was
the greatest day of my entire life in 41
years as you can see there but I learned
a lot about the super trofeo which is a
racing series that you use to bring in
buyers to the experience how's that
going it's going well we started in 2009
it's a one make race years we started
with the Gallardo in Europe in 2009 2012
then we had another series in Asia and
since two years we are doing it here in
North America today or this year we will
start with the budokan on the Super
Trofeo and yeah the first race is
next weekend at monza the 11th of april
in italy very cool you probably wouldn't
race an SUV although if you could it
would be the Auris are you any closer to
making that concept a realization the
lamborghini SUV we all think that a
third model is good for Lamborghini if
it's a third model then it will be an
SUV because it's a growing segment it's
a very emotional segment in the
four-door segment it's very well
distributed amongst the regions in this
world we have not the goal yet but I
hope this is coming soon of course the
predecessor is the lm002 one of my
all-time favorite cars also basically
became a Humvee what else can we expect
from Lamborghini as the Aventador is now
phasing out what's what's next no the
11th or is not phasing out the event
other is doing great and it will have
still a lot in in his backdrop we have a
lot of surprises coming up and I think
that Lamborghinis never speaking about
the future because we always have to be
better than the expectations of our
customers it's a dream car it's not a
car you buy to go from A to B and it's
something which should always exceed the
expectations alright well thank you so
much for spending some time with us this
morning really appreciate it thank you I
really appreciate the work you're doing
for mankind very much Stephan Winkelmann
CEO of Lamborghini